Qu'en penses de ce qui est
confronté Starred des
restaurateurs. Danny St-Pierre,
cuisinier, restaurateur et
propriétaire. Bonsoir.
- Bonsoir Monsieur Roy.
- Est-ce que le modèle doit
changer?
est-ce que c'est vrai que
restaurant où ça coûte plus cher
a drôlement moins les moyens de
bien payer ceux qui sont en
cuisine qu'un Saint-Hubert par
exemple?
- il y a beaucoup de facteurs
qui se mettent en place. De, le
coût des denrées. Quand on va
dans un restaurant où ça coûte
excessivement cher, les denrées
sont coûteuses. Augmenter le
prix de la facture. Ça prend
beaucoup de manipulation parce
que la cuisine haut de gamme,
c'est pas plusieurs humains qui
vont faire plusieurs petites
tâches spécifiques. Ce qu'il
faut comprendre dans ces
établissements, ce qu'il y a un
facteur de risque pour
l'employeur. Quand on travaille
avec des denrées comme ça puis
on accepte des salaires qui sont
plus bas, il y a une partie de
formation qui se continue. Vous
voyez sur le topo que vous
démontrez, il y a de petites
manipulations toutes faites, les
atmosphères la main là-dessus et
reçoit prendre des gens a la
sortie de l'école de l'ITHQ
école hôtelière de l'ensemble de
la province et leur formation va
se continue. Le quiproquo code
avec Monsieur Picard qui
proposait un salaire de base qui
était au-delà minimum, compensé
par les pourboires, s'appelle
commencer au bas de l'échelle.
Écoutez votre segment un peu
plus tôt.
- Vous dîtes que c'est normal.
Normal quelqu'un de l'ITHQ
commence au-delà minimum.
- Non, ce n'est pas seulement
ça. Il y a une grande différence
entre le Saint-Hubert et le pied
de cochon. Notre motivation est
différente d'aller travailler
dans l'un ou dans l'autre. Quand
on parle du pied de cochon, plus
de cochon a mon avis est une
école, un porte étendard de la
cuisine au Québec. On a eu
Anthony Bourdet qui est venu au
Québec a partir de sa qui a fait
crier notre province à part de
ça. Je vous dis, les salaires
sont augmentés parce qu'il y a
une pénurie de main-d'oeuvre. Il
y a une certaine forme
d'hypocrisie, ce qui a l'époque
il y a 20 ou 25 ans ne parlait
pas de la cuisine, on ne parlait
pas de la restauration comme ça.
Ça fait déjà bas. Le prélat
s'était élevé, les marges
étaient inexistantes et plus ça
va, plus les prix des denrées
augmentent, plus c'est d'avoir
déjà. On ne peut pas payer déjà
ce salaire.
- C'est vrai, donc, la marge
bénéficiaire est si petite.
Prenons qu'elle cochon. Vous
avez une restera. Donc c'est
vrai où vous dîtes ça mais dans
le fond vous empêchez plus?
- bien non, on n'empêche pas
plus. Quand les denrées sont
élevées, pour garder un marché
comme New York, Paris ou Las
Vegas. Le prix des denrées de
près les mêmes un peu partout.
Sa capacité de payer du marché
qui va déterminer ce qu'il va se
passer dans la tête donc dans
les salaires. Le vecteur
problème c'est qu'il y a
beaucoup de restaurants, ils se
font compétition. Le de l'ITHQ
disait que les gens font
compétition et n'osent pas
augmenter les prix parce qu'ils
ont peur d'avoir une salle à
manger qui va être dit : si tu
veux avoir des clients dans ta
place et que ton voisin va être
une poulet 25 $ et que toi tu
avoir 55 pour payer ton monde,
tu ne seras pas concurrentiel,
tu n'y arriveras pas.
- Vous dîtes, si on voulait
augmenter significativement les
salaires déjà en cuisine, il
faudrait faire payer les plats
beaucoup plus chers.
- Faudrait faire payer les plats
un peu plus chers, mais faudrait
parler surtout au gestionnaire
qui va engager les gens. Vous
savez, vous êtes en train de
faire des sushis, de la pizza,
du poulet, des pattes et de
sauter des salades et des
Pokemon, c'est beaucoup
d'humains différents par la même
tâche. Si vous avez une petite
salle à manger que vous offrez
tout ça, vous direz votre masse
salariale. La tendance en ce
moment et de retrait de services
pour maintenir un prix Al-Assad
qui va être bas. Quand on parle
de service aussi, je pense aux
pourboires en salle à manger
qu'on ne peut pas contrôler
parce que on parle d'une infime
partie de pourboires qui peut
être réparti dans l'ensemble de
la maison. Les normes du travail
protègent encore ça a
pourboires. Les vont être
pédestre et 80 $ et on laisse
couler 10 % du chiffre
d'affaires de la maison. Elle
excellait des iniquités qui se
créent. Le modèle, il est la
revoir aussi.
- On voulait, Danny St-Pierre,
beaucoup de propriétaires de
restaurants voulaient qu'on
réglemente cette question du
partage des pouvoirs. Ce n'est
pas passé. Pour vous, c'est une
des solutions?
- Je crois que oui. On parle de
masse de profits de 5 %. Il faut
que ça n'a quelque part en bon
français, something gotta give.
Ne pas vraiment d'avaries qui
nous arrivent.
Le problème du personnel est
réel.
- Il y a aussi la sécurité de
l'investissement de restaurateur
qui n'est pas considéré.
Dans la plupart des villes au
Québec, on peut ouvrir un
restaurant, c'est une norme
d'urbanisme. Si tu te qualifies
à être 25 m de notre
établissement et que dans ton
secteur tu peux être sur une rue
commerciale ou pas, tu peux
arriver demain matin ouvrir un
restaurant. Ce qui risque c'est
toujours un effet de nouveauté.
Un restaurant c'est un peu comme
un film. Beaucoup de gens se
fournissent et disent : on va
aller voir les nouveaux
Mousseau. On va aller au pied de
cochon. Après ces cochers et ils
n'y vont plus. On devrait
recommencer à adopter des
restaurant. Quand on aime un
endroit, on devrait le
revisiter. Je pense qu'il
faudrait avoir le courage
politique ou de faire :
on va arrêter de donner la
permission d'ouvrir des
restaurants...
- vous dites qu'il y en a eu
trop.
- Qu'on soit capable de revendre